ええええ
愛用シティボーイ東京に住んでる肇社長て
4位イーへ
[音楽]
これじゃ瑞雪ですというわけで肇社長です
ね実はおうちたくさん持ってるんですけど
も主に活動の拠点としている場所が2箇所
ありますひとつは静岡の3軒の豪邸
あの家ともう一個がここ音響でよく仕事
ある時は東京の子のお家
束まで出張バンドこの家に住んでることが
多いので実質2カ所で活動しているわけな
んですけども
今回
動画のタイトルにもある通り
東京の打つ
ピコしましたーー
道
[音楽]
音が入ってるけど言いますんでここですね
東京のこの家を引っ越すことになりました
いつから住んでるんだろうと思って調べた
んですけれども2020年の11月からだ
からもうちょうど2年ですね2年前から
ここに住んでました m を十全に気に
なると思うんですけどもなんで引っ越すの
かと言いますと単刀直入に言うと契約満了
ですね五年契約だったのでもちゃんと2年
経ったので契約終了ということで星にする
こともなくこれで無事に終了ですという
感じです1個勘違いしてほしくないんです
けども
大井田されたわけではないですね
まずでそう思われそうで声でノー射出され
たわけではなくそこあの心配しないで
ください
多分追い出されたわけではないんですけど
まぁ結構僕としては気に入ってが物件だっ
たのでちょっと寂しいなっていう思いが
かなり強いですめっちゃ気に入ってた子
だってさあのテレビの取材にもたくさん
切っていただいたりコーディネート台です
ねこの部屋のコーディネートが
1200万円くらいだったかな天
200万円でコーディネートしてもらった
この家を手放すのはねぇ
結構つがいし結構つらいんですけどな契約
満了ということでかといって東京にお家が
ないと仕事が成り立たないので引っ越すと
いうことになりましたよくでこの動画でて
いる時は僕多分ここに住んでないと思うん
でいますんじゃないからこそ話せること
結構あるんでちょっといろいろ話したいと
思いますこの家
六本木ですねギロトンに始めたぞ住んで
おりました2年間 a ぎろっぽんです
いやーすごい街ですね六本木もう外行っ
たらすごいギラギラの人が結構多くて
あんまり外に出ることはなかったんです
けど実は六本木に住んでました早速なので
も住んでないので生きるんですけど
外の景色を見ます
感じこれはん
の住んでない今だからこそみなさんに見せ
られる
最高級の景色
同オープン
うわーなんかめっちゃ悪いことする気が
すみせちゃだめじゃないというか住んで
たらこっち常に皆さんに見せてるって事
ですよこれうわぁああ開いてきました開い
てきました入ってきた
ni
[音楽]
meme
きた気がキター
母
rar
これ
皆さん特定おめでとうございますこれが
弾み冊をの前住んでた家の景色ですもう
多分分かる人には分かるんだろうな六法下
にあるマンションに住んでたわけです
ちなみにこれブームね別の事務所ですいや
景色本当にすごいんですよもうめっちゃ
綺麗
じゃっ系とかを最高なんですよ女の子と
この夜景見たらもうイチコロです原ねち
好きですよまあこの景色を見るの方も
終わりなんですけど六本木のあの高級
マンションに住んでおりましたもう理由は
シンプルで別に僕六法にしてみたいとか
じゃなかったんですけど見てこの道 p
ったらもう事務所なんですよ事務所に行く
の
[音楽]
here で殺させていただきました
ocn 4それだけのためにここに住んで
かん
[音楽]
なんか寂しくなってし2年もすると愛着も
バックし結構生活が出てるんですけども
ば最初インテリアコーディネータさんに
コーディネートしてもらったから
めちゃくちゃお部屋学的だったんですよ
[音楽]
から泥っぽいですいやーめっちゃいい物件
でしたもう長期に出たし
やっぱりで帰って来ていい景色みると
うわぁなんか頑張ったなぁ今日もというか
実は三つ目につながったリストがあって
いま振り返って思いますみなさん気になっ
てるとこですけどもやっち
どれぐらいだと思います
kk このおうちのやつないんだったと
思います
好き好きな薄毛系月にふさわしい景色だ
うわぁ
行ったあれ小沢せかけくれる逆光で真っ黒
700,000
apa
120万円を超えています
誰が借りる100人中なんですよね2年
近くかで打ったからぐわー2005
600万ぐらいかな2005600万円で
ここずっと住んでたわけですよでもさ俺
茶うけの家買っちゃったから会うことの大
弊社も知ってるからまあそれだけ素敵な
物件だったらまたどうかなっていう感じな
んですけど
120万円とからて済んでおりました
素敵なところでしてはこんな景色もご覧
くださいマジでどれこれないからみんな目
に焼き付けておいたねこれ
暖房ついてたな
公園怖い怖い怖い
同センターやベランダもみましょうか
どうせだったら最後に全部見せいただき
ましたよもう
[音楽]
ブーブーんですけども最後までブランド
doodle jump がぽい to
our れっ俺はグってキーに行か姉
ブーブー
掃除機あんまり出ることなかったけど家に
行ってきたここで一人でエクササイズとか
してますぬー
ご覧くださいこちらです
俺が120円の決議です
夜に見せなかったなぁう国内でもすごいよ
マッチマッチ町じゃあめっさ素敵でしたよ
快適で六本木のジェスチャの六本木って
いうのがもうずっと防いだからさあすごい
抵抗があるんですけど始めた六本木のうち
はこれでお別れという感じでございます
もう一度次の物件住み始めてだけで
引っ越したけど新しい打ちちょっと言って
良いでしょうか
[音楽]
rohana
これ
ビッグコードリーダーしてもう今日から
真っ白管理 c てございますと言う
と僕が知らないで同番組から不思議や
もらえるんですよね一応引っ越ししたと
いう報告だけせていただきましたーーー
日々
はこうです
普段
棒があるのねー
サッコマドゥ
だっての
夏目大が特定されちゃうん
ここで統計養殖されているなと思うやり方
はどうぞはありませんので
じゃあ
me
pabo
tana いっ